give and go brogden inside reverse layup
i want to win a championship here i feel
as i fit into the identity of this team
very well as an underdog and this team
always exceeds
expectations it takes after the midwest
city that really fights for everything
they have
i've been asked to be the leader of this
team affect the game on both ends of the
floor
flip criticism go on a tad and be elite
a lot of the time i try to block it out
but for the criticism that i do
here it's fueled in my fire
technology is allowing the game to be
viewed more widely it's made it more
interesting for fans being able to see
the different views being able to
see the game sort of through a different
lens in a different angle
for me personally i feel as i fit into
the identity of this team as an underdog
that over performs
that proves people wrong great move
i think we have the building blocks to
be really really good to the elite that
will allow us to win the championship
ultimate
i'ma leave with my voice i'm gonna make
sure people are organized that they know
what they're doing
and i'm a lead by example i'm a guy
that's gonna be fearless on the court so
that my teammates can follow